Well
hello, today is May 31, 3
González greets you and these are the most relevant news
of the day. The
Las Vegas Metropolitan Police continue the
investigation to identify a child
who was found lifeless near the
Mount Trail in Springs
downtown.  National for Missing
& Exploited Children released this
digitally enhanced image of a
police sketch after the boy was
misidentified over the
weekend Detectives believe the boy
is between the ages of 8 and 12 Police
say there are no missing children
locally matching the
description
and today is memorial day and we
take a moment to honor the
women and men who
served the country one of the
largest local ceremonies is
happening at the burlan cemetery in
downtown  The city members
of Nevada's congressional delegation and
Las Vegas Mayor Carolyn Goodman
will pay their respects as well s
Many people are expected to gather today at the
Veterans Memorial Cemetery
in Southern Nevada located on Butter High
Way where a ceremony will be held in
the courtyard outside the chapel at one o'clock in
the afternoon
and a reminder clip is associated with the
las vegas coalition to
kill and stay safe live is
offering $5 off a
ride now until
6pm just use code smart white
toni khoury one to get the offer and
it's while supplies last
also expected to  lots of people
going for lunch ride today
lake staff say
boaters should check
boat ramps before
heading out for bei harvard putter launch they
will have multiple ramps open today
remember to leave early to avoid
rush officials  del lago also
had to close huevos
beach yesterday for a few hours due to
capacity restrictions
and weather  temperatures we will have
sunny skies on this holiday monday it will be a
hot day with highs as close
to 100 degrees and we are still
three weeks into summer
but this week it will feel very
hot
our temperatures jump to 100
starting tomorrow  And they will be like this all
week, so take care of yourself and pay
close attention to the young, the
elderly and the pets. Happy
Monday, Andrés González informed you, and this
was about the news now in
Spanish
[Music]